breathe in breathe out with every breath
the body is replenished and cleansed a
process made possible by two of the
body's most important and delicate
organs the lungs are two major
components of the respiratory system
soft light and elastic these organs are
primed for taking in and filling up with
air each lung is subdivided into
compartments called lobes the right lung
has three and the left lung which is
slightly smaller to accommodate the
positioning of the heart has to this
compartmentalization provides a feel
safe for the lungs so that if one lobe
is damaged the four other lobes may
remain intact and able to function the
lobes are also connected to separate
branches called bronchi of the trachea
which delivers air from the nose and
mouth these branches provide the lobes
independent supplies of air within each
lobe the bronchi split off into numerous
smaller offshoots that end in air sacs
known as alveoli these sacs are
responsible for a crucial exchange of
air when a person inhales oxygen fills
the alveoli the alveolar walls which
contains countless capillaries are so
thin that the oxygen inhaled can pass
through them and be absorbed by blood
cells within the capillaries a similar
transaction occurs in the opposite
direction
carbon dioxide waste transported in the
bloodstream can pass through the
alveolar walls from there they are
expelled with every exhalation
this exchange of gases known as
respiration is what gives the
respiratory system its name because of
their intake of air the lungs are
constantly exposed to the elements and
sometimes fall victim to them lung
conditions may develop such as emphysema
which for some is caused by the
inhalation of tobacco smoke and
pneumonia which can be caused by the
inhalation of infectious organisms
altogether these and other lung diseases
are the fourth leading cause of death in
the United States the lungs are delicate
organs but despite their vulnerability
their anatomical design allows them to
stay strong and play a vital role in
fueling the body
[Music]